every single person who wants to do
something with their life and has done
something with their life has gone
through the exact chapter that you're
going through and it's the lonely
chapter it's the chapter where you don't
fit in with your own friends but you
don't have the outcomes yet to fit into
a new group of friends and you're doing
this thing you're doing these free
tutorials online to try and figure out
how to set up a podcast and you're going
through this and you're like is this
even worth it because you have no signs
of success the sign of success is the
hate that you get along the way and what
you can't do is bend the knee to their
hate and fit back into the Conformity
because it's comfortable and it's warm
because like in The Matrix when Trinity
opens the door when Neo's about to go
take the red pill and he wants to get
out of the car she says Neo you've been
down that road and you know exactly
where it leads and I know that's not
where you want to be and then he closes
the door like right now this moment that
you're going through is Trinity opening
the door and being like you could go
back but then you'd have to remember
exactly what the reason was that you
decided not to go out to begin with is
because you listen to this podcast and
you consume this content you're like I
can do more than this and you start to
see the person that you could be and
you're like this does start to feel like
hell